hey everyone Deo here and today we're
back at with the Pinnacle of all domain
videos and this we are going to cover
all of the known domains that have been
introduced to us or mentioned throughout
the series so far a domain expansion is
the most incomparable technique of any
jiujitsu user it is the peak of the
essence all pulled forth and imagined
through an innate domain that itself is
covered with a barrier to construct it
in a different space What jutu sorcery
hand signs words dance and other forms
of Expressions all expand the level to
which someone can manipulate curse
energy a domain expansion is expanded
through the use of one of these actions
for example mahito opens his mouth wide
to perform his while Deon forms a symbol
on their
torso first of the domain expansions
that we see throughout the series coffin
of the Iron Mountain is the special
grade disaster cursor Joo Supreme art
this fiery domain meticulously
replicates the inner sanctum of a
roaring live volcano encased within an
impenetrable Stone chamber it's coloss
fle walls and floors are rled with
gaping crevices that gush forth copious
amounts of molten magma this results in
a temperature so hot that any typical
jutu user would instantly succumb to
spontaneous combustion upon setting foot
within the domain fittingly dubbed the
coffin of the Iron Mountain this is a
lethal type domain that is equipped with
a guaranteed hits to activate the lethal
short hit technique the user can control
with ease all of the lava and molten
rock flowing around the inside of the
domain and direct it towards the target
seen right after we witnessed the Iron
Mountain and limited void is one of if
not the most advanced technique and the
vast arsenal of Limitless due to
obviously being the stronger and more
refined of the two domains Gojo's
unlimited void easily overpowered and
suppressed the effects of [__] when it
comes to the effects of unlimited void
this domain inserts the user and their
targets inside Limitless itself a
boundless void filled with infinite
flowing knowledge within this vast space
a constant flow of complex information
floods into the minds of the targets
overwhelming them to the extent that
they become completely paralyzed the
incapacitation of the target occurs due
to a unique phenomenon where the target
is both aware of everything and yet
unable to perceive or sense anything at
the same time it as if every action
they've ever taken in their life has
been repeatedly imposed upon them
causing them to suffer a slow and
inevitable demise it's worth noting that
this effect doesn't actually impact the
user or anyone they are in physical
contact with so if you were to be St in
this domain the only way to survive it
would be getting a hold of Gojo or
repairing that destroyed brain of yours
with reverse curse
technique third up in nearing the final
seconds of mjo's battle against Hanami
and Yuji he was able to discover
something by using his death as an
inspiration opening his mouth NATO
throws up miniature gang sign hand seals
formed by tiny hands inside of his mouth
to activate his domain expansion the
self- embodiment of perfection this
Infamous domain creates a vast dark
space where Target encounters enormous
hands that come together to form a
flowerlike shape these giant hands are
connected by multiple arms creating a
netlike cage that encircles mjo's
intended victim the self- embodiment of
perfection works by amplifying the
effectiveness of mjo's curse technique
idle Transfiguration and ensuring it
directly affects the target Soul
instantly being inside the self-
embodiment of perfection is described as
feeling as if you're figuratively in the
palm of mjo himself du to like how Idol
Transfiguration works this domain
expansion is an almost sure kill type of
domain the only way like one would
actually survive is if they had some
form of ability that allowed them to
block damage to their soul directly one
thing I do want to point out about
domain expansions if given time a domain
user can easily decide who was caught by
the domain as we saw with mjo's first
bout against Yuji and N armi however
though when the preparation time is
extremely limited or the conditions
change one can't specifically choose who
is caught by it this here can lead to a
few drawbacks of of mjo's domain and if
he does accidentally touch the wrong
Soul it can backfire with drastic
consequences next up and using its
fingers to craft hand signs the small
poox deity can activate their domain
graveyard and instantly trap an opponent
inside as the name suggests the domain
itself is just a graveyard what's
special about it though is how it plays
on the cursor innate gravestone
technique due to a domain usually being
granted with an automatic H graveyard
enhances the curse technique and
automatically traps the opponent with
the highest curse energy output in a
coffin then once the conditions are
fulfilled it guarantees that that person
will be infected with small pox and die
these conditions are that the curse has
to count down from three and if it
reaches one then it wins as someone
escapes the coffin though it can
continuously use the short hit technique
over and over again to trap them on top
of that the gravestone itself deals
critical damage when putting someone
underground next up and I somehow
initially forgot that we saw mami's
first use of his domain during like the
last few moments of season 1 although
not fully able to be constructed into a
sphere CA Shadow Garden when expelled in
an environment that allows it saturates
the surroundings with dense shadowy
liquid this allows any user of the tense
Shadows technique to summon multiple
shami at once and have free manipulation
over all of the Shadows in the area
additionally it also brings forth a
sizable structure resembling two columns
of spinal bone interconnected by some
form of nerve endings however this
object vanishes shortly after the
initial activation of the domain anyone
standing in the shadow will have to
reinforce their feet with cursed energy
or risk falling into the abyss below
them this includes the actual use of
themselves if one was to fall into the
liquid likee Shadows there is no boyancy
resistance or oxygen anyone who has
dropped into them will fall indefinitely
and you know I wonder where Megami
currently is right
now next up D gon's domain expansion
Horizon of the captivating scander is
activated like I said earlier in the
video with a seal on his stomach this
results in the creation of a Serene
tropical beach type domain this domain
is often described as peaceful and the
water near the beach is shallow enough
for someone to stand in this domain did
actually make an appearance during
season 1 however it was only for a
moment while Deon was still in his
cursed womb state within the Horizon of
the captivating scander deonate
technique ensures that the sugar gami
crafted by him automatically strike
their designated targets from the
perspective of those being targeted
these fish like shikami seemingly
materialize out of nowhere making them
exceptionally hard to predict this is
like because the shikami actually only
come into existence at the very moment
they make contact with the target one of
the techniques inside of deon's domain
that takes advantage of the Shad effect
death swarm takes the form of multiple
large Marine like chicagami and has them
constantly attack until the opponent is
devoured the only way to stop this
Endless Sea of death is to disrupt the
cursed Spirits domain and glitch out the
Shad function of
it true to its name and next up on the
list of course the malevolent Shrine not
the freaking kitchen creates an area
focused around a small singular altered
buddist Shrine that has been distorted
to instead enshrine demons the shrine
somewhat resembles a chudo and if you
remember back to where exactly meami was
looking for sua's finger during the
early episodes of the Season well I
think it you know it kind of makes a
little bit more sense now anyways
anyways instead of the like the
obviously picturesque peaceful shrines
that these deities have sakuna Shrine or
the freaking kitchen as some nut at
crunchy roll decided to mess it up and
call it is encircled by murky dark
colored water and the ground is adorned
with horned skulls the roof is
embellished with protruding horns and
suspended human skulls the four
entrances to the shrine take the form of
large grotesque mouths featuring
humanlike teeth and tongues unlike
almost every other domain seen in the
series so far sakuna domain is built
different instead of just like imagining
an innate environment and surrounding it
with a barrier to give it structure the
king of curses Rian sakuna is equipped
with a barrierless domain an art so far
beyond normal comprehension it's as if
someone is painting in thiner without
the use of even a canvas the malevolent
shrines guaranteed head ability enables
it to ruthlessly slash through anything
within its effective range until only
dust remains to do this zakuna employs
two types of slashing attacks namely has
known and extremely Trust cleave and
dismantle these two slicing attacks will
not stop slashing until the domain is
disengaged or sakuna is too severely
injured to sustain it any longer sakuna
obviously you know also has the capacity
to choose between these two attacks
based on the target type opting for
dismantle against an animate objects and
cleave for subjects with curse energy
I'm just assuming off the top of my head
right here that dismantle would actually
be able to work on people like toi and
Mari people who are considered buildings
by curse energy this is also her sakono
was able to cut the world of anyone was
confused he used dismantled to cut the
inanimate World Behind Infinity itself
so you kind of like get that a little
bit more now if you couldn't understand
it he didn't actually hit Gojo directly
he cut the globe behind Gojo and man was
just in the way also on top of that
we've seen sakuna Implement a few
different conditions into the structure
of how his domain is formed for example
during his battle against Gojo zuna's
domain grew Beyond unlimited void's
barrier with the domain's barrier being
weak to like attacks on it out of shell
Gojo's domain was crushed by malevolent
Shrine slashing attacks and he was
immediately struck by its C Miss attack
throughout that long battle some of the
binding vals he placed upon his domain
were like removing malevolent shrines
guaranteed head effect within unlimited
voids effective area or narrowing down
its effective range similar to when he
used it in shabuya to like Dodge meami
and stuff in exchange sakuna was granted
increased power to counter Gojo's own
domain improvisations I didn't like
mention those improvisations during
Gojo's infinite void or unlimited void
part of the video as they technically
qualify as binding vals and I'll stick
there in a binding valve video if you
guys want to see that in the future
seeing as we're here now though simply
Gojo could do a bunch of like similar
improvisations he could expand his
domain shell or reduce the overall size
of the domain to a basketball which was
something most Sorcerers deemed
absolutely impossible cuz how are you
supposed to imagine yourself being that
small or something you know either way
moving
forth seventh I think no one domains
we've seen throughout the series so far
comes from the first opponent our main
cast faces during the King game heri
hiara deadly sentencing creates a large
courtroom where the user and their
target standing across from one another
playing the roles of prosecutor and
defendant unlike most of the domains
we've seen throughout the series and
just due to hegar Ruma learning the use
of his technique and private deadly
sentencing is a type of domain that
isn't considered lethal it can still be
lethal in the end but it doesn't
actually contain a can't miss attack
like others way back in the early days
of jiujitsu Discovery probably before
even sakuna a domain expansion wasn't
used as a finishing move instead they
forced those who were caught inside to
abide by the rules or bindings of that
domain's technique once caught inside of
you know like hegar's deadly sentencing
the law type curse technique imbued into
the domain allows the user to prosecute
the target with a shikami called
judgment inside this domain no physical
violence is permitted for either party
initially as it starts out judg men
reveals the accusations against the
accursed which consists of real crimes
they may or may have not committed
despite judgment having access to all of
the information about everyone within
the domain this knowledge is not given
to the user in the trial the final
decision depends on what each side says
after hearing the accusations the person
being accused gets one shot to defend
themselves they can choose to stay quiet
admit guilt or say they didn't even do
it if they deny they can you know
obviously even lie just like you can in
real law the goal for the accused person
person is to convince judgment that
they're innocent and clear any doubts
that it might have of them once it's the
prosecutor's turn and deadly sentencing
they get a single chance to speak this
statement is like a counterargument
using evidence given by judgment for
review the evidence comes in a sealed
envelope held by the prosecutor the
information inside isn't treated as
definite proof and it stays closed until
after the prosecutor speaks keeping the
accused in the dark however judgment
shares the info with the prosecutor as
soon as they get the envelope after
after both the prosecutor and the
defense have had their say judgment
steps in to give a legal verdict if the
accused is deemed guilty they face one
of several possible sentences though the
user of this technique isn't certain
which one it'll be the severity of the
punishment can vary with the more
Severus crimes leading to harsher
penalties in certain cases and the worst
obviously being death before the verdict
is given judgment often dishes out a
punishment called confiscation which
stops the guilty person from using curse
techniques once the the verdict is given
the domain expansion disappears and the
punishment takes effect on the guilty
party straight away however if the
accused is found guilty without openly
admitting it they can ask for another
trial and judgment has to agree this is
called an appeal and even though it has
been like specifically stated in the
series I'm assuming someone has the
right to at least two appeals just like
we do in real
life when it comes to this next
expansion idle death gamble we are
probably going to be here for a little
while this technique is so hard for my
small brain to wrap itself around it
really is one of the most mindboggling
techniques seen so far from jiutu Kaizen
it's not crazy blowing up City levels of
like mindboggling or like technical wise
using stuff from like outer space but
hakari had to just go and be a creative
genius with way too much time on his
hands firstly the full name for his
domain expansion is Idle death gamble CR
private Pure Love Train version 1 out of
239 the CR stands for card reader and
it's actually based on a real penko
machine with obviously the same name
dude is like a total degenerative
mangarita or a gambler probably both in
actuality the user of this to man's goal
is to hit Jackpot by lining up three of
the same symbols decorated with the
characters of pure private love train
there are seven different characters in
the pure private love train series
starting from the main hero with the
number seven we've got Yuki Yamaguchi
the main heroine and number three yum
asagi number six in Yuki's youngest
sister Sakaya Yamaguchi number four and
the dude who you know can't tell the
difference between a guitar and a bass
hok Yuki's current Boss by day she is a
project manager but when Night Comes
damn girl ah yeah I know I had to
mention her and I I I cring myself doing
that the number two s Amano gawa which I
probably got completely wrong but you
know who cares and then next up Yuki's
current coworker and number five Suzuka
Shimizu then finally number one Yuki's
old friend and currently A Bank Thief
aito what such a weird ability this one
now with all the characters out of the
way once a jackpot is achieved it grants
the user unlimited curse energy along
with that it gives them a fully
automatic reverse CSE technique that
lasts for exactly 4 minutes and 11
seconds the reason for the extremely
specific amount of time on this
technique is because the theme for like
pure private love train admiring you
runs for that exact amount of time so
had the uh mention jackpot the user
needs to engage actively in the game's
Dynamics facing a slim 1 out of 2 39
odds obviously you know they have to
spin to get these odds here or whatever
you know like to to win once the domain
is activated the rules of the game are
instantaneously transferred to the
opponent's mind this is done through
like taking advantage of the domain
short hit technique hakari uses like the
short hit to transfer the rules and not
damage so as a trade-off for him the
construction and infusion of a curse
technique into his domain happens
unrealistically fast completing in less
than 0.2 seconds man could have probably
stopped all those crafty 0.2 domain from
happening in shabuya if he was there but
you know that's a completely different
line of thinking plus along that same
line of thinking and just due to how
quickly he can actually throw up his
gang signs and makes this domain
extremely proficient in activating first
before others moving on to like the
Dynamics of how the game works inside of
a domain initially once started the two
opponents will appear on a neutral stage
before they throw hands the user has the
ability to create three distinct visual
effect indicators shutter doors Reserve
balls and consecutive effects the door
and balls serve as offensive Maneuvers
while consecutive effects act as a
defensive indicator rewinding a sequence
to undo damage doors and reverse balls
come in a green red or gold Rarity to
symbolize a higher chance at a jackpot
rainbow colored indicators or redoing
four consecutive effects guarantees a
jackpot in itself the user also has the
option to select which visual indicator
to generate but the outcome is LIF up to
chance creating one or more visual
indicators advances the stage to a Ry
scenario and veiling two out of the
three necessary numbers for a jackpot
when it comes to this new thing that I
just brought up before a Ry scenario
these are scenarios involving the efor
mentioned characters from the pure
private love train penko machine from
what we have seen there are four
different RI sequences with different
chances of hitting a jackpots the final
train scenario is different though and
has over an 80% chance of a jackpot each
of the sequences will change the layout
of the domain changing it to resemble a
different stage then it will use those
characters of the pure private love
train in a different way for that stage
I'm not going to go over all of the
different scenarios in themselves
otherwise oh my Lord we are going to be
here for a while this is for the fact
that we haven't even been able to
discuss what the hell happens if hakari
fails to even hit a jackpot pretty much
because like a true Gambler hakari
understands that The House Always Wins
if someone fails to hit a jackpot then
the scenario will revert the stage back
to its original form the cycle continues
until the user either secures a victory
or exhausts all chances to do so with
the number of possible attempts
diminishing with each unsuccessful
jackpot during the initial activation of
consecutive expansions the likelihood of
hitting the jackpot actually exceeds 20%
when a jackpot is achieved the domain
vanishes and admiring you begins its 4
minutes and 11 second counter playing
loudly around the user like I mentioned
to start with the user receives a bonus
of unlimited curse energy for the entire
duration of the song This unrestricted
curse energy comes with no limitations
at all so for those few minutes he's
actually considered special grade and
the user can receive additional bonus
amounts at random intervals throughout
the round this along with like the
automatic use of reverse curse technique
prevents the user's body from sustaining
damage and renders them effectively
invulnerable for 4 minutes and 11
seconds once this song comes to an end
the user's curse energy returns to its
normal level and their curse technique
is fully replenished this in turn allows
them to activate their domain repeatedly
on the condition that they achieve a
jackpot each time with consecutive uses
of this domain the condition of the
previous one will still be active if the
user aligns three odd numbers the stage
begins with Advanced probability rather
than the neutral state in the case of
aligning even numbers the stage
commences with faster spins meaning that
he can bring about a jackpot quicker
even with a less of a percentage
additionally there's a possibility for
the stage to start in head in
probability mode this is actually taken
directly from a penko machine and is
usually akin to faster spins but with an
elevated probability of hitting the
jackpot that's kind of everything we
know about Good Old haki's domain
expansion there when I think about it
it's nice having The Binding valow of
showing one's hand it means we all get
you know at some point or another an
explanation of a user's ability unless
you know like the sorcerer is far too
strong and they don't even need to
mention it but you know anyways
anyways professional hater Nao yenan
came back with like one of the craziest
powerups in the series has or inspiring
domain expansion Fally named time cell
Moon Palace is my favorite name for a
abbility scene in the series and like
the previous few domains that we've been
over casting ne's domain is pretty stock
standard it creates a black empty
environment like most other sorceress
domains with a few floating organisms
seen about it in the center is a large
main stage that is made up of like a
flesh-like substance this pathway leads
down to a large eye that is situated
directly behind the Caster the domain's
auto hit feature sends out an injecting
tape of Animation frames that Jabs into
the necks of its chosen targets if
anyone makes a single movement inside of
the domain they must adhere by the 24
FPS rule of projection sorcery if they
don't follow those rules unlike the
original technique they don't get stuck
in a frame instead it will result in
body-wide injuries on a cellular level
like most domains time cell Moon Palace
enhances the accuracy of the embedded
curse technique honing it in on
individual cells freezing these
individual cells disrupts the normal
functioning resulting in athora of tiny
cuts across the entire body r in the
Target immobile after being afflicted by
this any attempt to force movement may
actually lead to the sing of an entire
limb this is an extremely lethal domain
however sadly for naoya the dude got hit
by a freaking
building next up and second to last in
all of the knowing domains womb
profusion is a terrifyingly deadly
ability in the hands of no one other
than kinjaku himself as we just saw with
sakuna in the anime and due to how like
the battle was playing out against Yuki
kinjaku can expand his domain without
enclosing it inside of a barrier I'm
assuming that it's also possible for him
to enclose it in a barrier but because
of how tingen was targeting barriers he
purposely decided to not use one on it
to activate this domain the user places
the backside of their fingers together
and interlocks them enlarging the domain
gives rise to a totem like Tower covered
in grotesque merged faces resembling
cursed Spirits anyone ins snared within
the reach of its unvoid strike
experiences an explosion impact AK into
a direct hit from maximum uzaki although
the specific characteristics of this
attack remain unknown in my eyes though
and just because of like the curs spirit
styling of this domain I believe that
it's most likely the domain that sugu
could have achieved if he didn't pass on
originally lastly now out of the knowing
domains inside of jiutu Kaizen Yu's
three-fold Affliction is not actually
deadly in itself Instead This domain
short head effect works with the users
constructed items that they may bring
into the domain
opening this domain results in a mainly
empty area and dispersed with like
oversized organic structures suspended
inside of it sticking with Yu's big bug
theme so far these structures be a
resemblance to the detached brains and
spinal nerve cords of insects as I
mentioned above the main feature of the
three-fold Affliction is bringing a
construction thing that Yu made into the
domain mainly her perfect sphere
creation if this ability enters the
domain it will result in her win unless
it's sakuna or Gojo and that's pretty
much it so far that we've seen that
would be able to actually stop it so now
with that we're at the end of what we've
seen domain wise who do you think is
going to be the next to like get a
domain and everything if you were to be
chucked into the world of jiujitsu
kaisen and had to choose one type of
domain what would it be no need to like
think of curse techniques or anything
like that just the main expansions I'd
love to know down below me I I
personally I think I'd want to take
kaku's womb profusion the domain just
seems insanely deadly and super
unexplored which is something I actually
love in itself I just I love exploring
things and stuff obviously it's why I
have this channel that brings me to
another Point as well if you guys
haven't noticed how many of those
domains feature like random body parts
or like nerves and spinal things it's
like domains imagine a section of some
imaginary beast and bring it forth then
paste their technique into it in some
way but I don't know like how it would
do that exactly I'm pretty sure it's
just what it is and it's some like
imagined space that the sorcerer is
creating everything but I I like the
idea of there being some like overriding
Beast creation or something that you
could make I wonder if the keing game is
going to result in a merger of all of
those parts to create like the
monolithic creature that kinjaku is
wanting to bring to life you know that
one that we've seen in some panels and
stuff is his big plan of merging 100
million people so much I want to know
and it's just truly why I love this
series if you have enjoyed this video
and found it insightful at all feel free
to leave a like and help push this video
to 5K likes as it really helps out with
you know pushing my content to a bunch
of new amazing people plus if you are
new around here and want to watch more
content just like this then subscribe
also just want to shout out to all my
amazing patreons and thank you for all
the support over there recently it's
been absolutely amazing but for now it's
been your professional degenerate de
Volo and I will see you all and a BS
bye